[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] الساعة 4:00 صباحًا الآن ، إنها
المرة الأولى التي أسمع فيها صلاة مبكرًا ، لذا
لا أعرف ما إذا كان
ذلك مبكرًا بسبب رمضان
[موسيقى]
سأحاول الصوم اليوم ولكن
لم أقرر بعد ما إذا كنت
سأفترض أن الماء سيكون صعبًا جدًا ،
فقد كان الجو حارًا جدًا مؤخرًا ، لا
أعرف كيف يفعل الناس ذلك ولكن منذ أن حصلت
عليه من أجل الصلاة ، سأعرف أن
لديك  بعض الماء فقط في حالة ما إذا
كنت أقوم بالصيام منذ أن سمعت
الصلاة هذا الصباح وفي الواقع
بمجرد انتهاء الصلاة اعتقدت
أنه ليس شروق الشمس ولكن يمكنني شرب
بعض الماء الذي تعرفه أعد نفسي
لليوم ولكن في الواقع  اكتشفت بعد
ذلك بمجرد انتهاء الصلاة
أن يبدأ يوم الصيام ، لذلك
بدأت الأمر بشكل خاطئ بعض الشيء ولكن
بعد ذلك سارت على الطريق الصحيح وكنت
أقوم بالصيام من الماء
والصوم عن الطعام  لقد كان أسهل مما كنت
أعتقد من حيث الطعام ، لكن
المياه كانت صعبة بعض الشيء ،
أشعر بنفسي  بدأت أشعر بالعطش
خاصة لأننا نتجول في ضوء
الشمس وبدأت شفتي
تجف قليلاً ، فأنا أستخدم بالفعل بعض الطاقة الفولتية
الآن على ما يرام ، كما لو
كنت على ما يرام حتى فجأة
لم أكن على ما
يرام  أنا فقط متعب وأنا جائع
وعطش وهناك زجاجة
ماء يحدقون في وجهي أنا أتضور جوعا أنا على
وشك أن آكل عجلة القيادة
[الموسيقى]
يجب أن أحب ذلك الذي أعرفه
لذلك انتهيت للتو من أول موعد لي على
مسدسي وكانت في الواقع تجربة رائعة حقًا
لقد كانت رائعة إذا
اعتقدت الآن أنه من المثير للاهتمام حقًا
معرفة أنك تعرف جميع
الأطعمة المختلفة والأفكار الكامنة وراءها
ولكن أعتقد ما أعجبني  أكثر ما يتعلق
بها هو التجربة الاجتماعية وكيف أنها
تجمع الناس معًا عندما
يكونون صائمين وكلهم
يمرون بهذا معًا ثم عندما
يجلسون ويتناولون وجبة رائعة
ويتحدثون ويستمتعون بصحبة بعضهم البعض.
أعتقد أن هذا كان ممتعًا حقًا
الخبرة